Weil sie dort all diese Art von Herumhängen und Routing-Dingen machen werden.
Warum?
Ich weiß es nicht genau, aber ich weiß, dass es seit den neunziger Jahren etwas mit Nigeria zu tun hat.
Wie dem auch sei, also loggen sie sich in die Körper ein, testen sie und sie verwurzeln den Strom hin und her.
Sie beobachten, wie Knotenmodule mit ihren Nanokonstellationen in Echtzeit in die Neuronen der Menschen hinein- und herauskommen.
Ich habe das schon einmal für unsere Zwecke auf dem Kanal gezeigt.
Mit all dem werde ich das schließen und ich werde es einfach nochmal durchgehen.
2013 haben wir einen neuen Virus gefunden.
Wir haben es registriert, wir haben es mit all unserer DNA, Bewerbung und Zusammenarbeit durchgesehen.
Aber sie wissen es bereits, und ich bin mir sicher, dass das Verteidigungsministerium der Russischen Föderation weiterhin die militärischen und biologischen Aktivitäten der USA analysiert.
und ihre Verbündeten in der Ukraine und anderswo auf der Welt.
Also, mit anderen Worten, wenn ich eine seriöse Person bin und zu meinem Kanal, dem Synergy Channel, komme.
Mein Name ist Sabrina Wallace.
Ich bin ein nichtinvasiver und habe zwei Überlebende aus Dhaka.
Ich wurde nicht zur MPD gemacht, ich mochte die anderen für den nichtinvasiven Eintritt.
Ich wurde von Jesus Christus von Nazareth gerettet.
Er hat ein Loch in die Dimension gerissen.
Und ich weiß, dass viele Leute so tun wollen, als wäre ich darauf aufgespießt worden.
Und ich bin einfach verwirrt.
Bin ich nicht.
Und es tut mir leid, wer auch immer du bist, weil ich weiß, dass es deine Gefühle verletzt.
Das ist wirklich das, was und wen ich gesehen habe.
Das ist mein Gott.
Und genau das hat er getan.
Und neben mir standen zwei Verwandte, die 1800 Jahre alt waren, voller Nano, voller Gold.
Und sie sind sofort gestorben.
Und ihnen wurde gesagt, dass Sabrina keinen nichtinvasiven Zutritt hat.
Sie haben nicht zugehört.
Sie sind sofort gestorben.
Und mein Leben wurde durch und durch zu zu einer Karikatur des Lebens.
Wenn ich also eine Menge davon zurückentwickle, helfe ich dabei, das Internet von der Einwahl bis zur Breitbandverbindung aufzubauen.
Als ich herausfand, dass es Body Area Networks schon so lange gibt, wusste ich, wofür sie Kinder mit dem Sucherfernrohr benutzen, ich wusste, was sie die ganze Zeit machten, weil niemand von Ihnen da draußen zu wissen schien, dass der Körper die beste Antenne ist.
Was ich nicht wusste, als ich weiterhin all diese Art von Dokumentation mit den Biomediziningenieuren und der Biomedizintechnik durchging, war, wie viele Menschen darüber gelogen haben, was sie täglich für die Arbeit tun, indem sie den menschlichen Körper jeden Tag und die ganze Zeit mit mehreren Systemen verbinden.
Es ist ein Job, mehrere Jobs.
Also wurde ich sehr wütend auf diejenigen unter Ihnen da draußen, die Profis sind, die niemandem gesagt haben, was zur Hölle mit dem Graphen in diesen Impfstoffen vor sich geht, weil es kein Impfstoff ist, wenn Graphen benötigt wird, Graphen ist neurotoxisch.
Wir wissen das, also haben wir einige Dinge geändert.
Das ist in Ordnung.
Aber wenn du den Leuten nicht sagst, was du wirklich tust, und ihnen dann sagst, dass es ein Virus ist, musst du jetzt deinen Job verlieren, deine Familie verlieren.
Gott weiß was.
Seit vier Jahren nenne ich das den Inbegriff von Feigheit.
Und du kannst den Leuten nicht einfach sagen, dass du bereits augmentiert und hybridisiert bist, synthetische Telepathie, biomedizinisches Zeug.
Ich meine, es ist schon erledigt.
Und du erzählst den Leuten nicht, dass du unterwegs mit deiner VR, XR und MMR eine Fernoperation hast.
Und wenn ich stattdessen zu „Wenn ich zurückkomme“ übergehe und mir die Synergien mit all dem vorlese und wir uns die Silogeografie, die dynamische Bevölkerungskontrolle und die Synergien ansehen, habe ich es immer wieder in Laiensprache sagen hören.
Das nennt man menschliche Haltung.
Wir geben die Datenbanken an ein lokales Überwachungsprogramm weiter.
Überwachungsprogramm?
Überwachungsprogramm.
Es ist Überwachung auf allen Ebenen, Krankheitsüberwachung im Jahr 2016.
Sie können ihnen immer noch nicht einmal sagen, dass sie mit der Cloud verbunden sind.
Wir haben jede Menge junge Menschen, jeden Tag, die ganze Zeit, mit all dem beschäftigt, weil sie bereit sind für die neue Smart City.
Sie haben nicht das Gefühl, beobachtet zu werden.
Sie haben das Gefühl, beschützt zu werden.
Sie hatten keine Eltern.
Sie hatten einen Bildschirm, während die Eltern da saßen und, Oh, das Internet sagten.
Wir.
Verdammt noch mal, ihr schlagkräftigen Feiglinge.
Oh, wir werden es beenden.
Du machst kein verdammtes Ding aus.
Diese Satelliten, einige von ihnen.
Sie sind seit fast 2000 Jahren bei IBM tätig.
Also elektronisches integriertes Krankheitsüberwachungssystem.
Ist das gut genug für alle.
Du willst dich jetzt mit der W-Band befassen?
Ich meine, ich weiß nicht, es sind Ihre Einheimischen, die die Kontrolle über dieses Zeug haben, was wahrscheinlich der Grund ist.
Großartig.
Und das Logo für die Krankheitsüberwachung ist in Japan ein bisschen O.
Die Überwachung der COVID-19-Krankheit sieht so aus.
In Japan haben wir unseren eigenen Kurs.
Das tun wir.
Das tut jeder.
Und wenn Sie es bemerken, sieht ihre COVID-19-Reaktion wie die Metamaterialien aus.
Niemand wird darüber sprechen.
Also Professor Ian, während er sie an Leute verkauft, oh, schauen Sie, wir haben kleine mechanische Fehler, um sie hier rein zu bekommen.
Wenn du nicht reinkommst, wo auch immer du reinfährst, um es injizieren zu lassen, weil wir die Kontrolle haben und du nicht.
Du wurdest bereits infiziert.
Dann komme ich hierher zum Rumble-Kanal, wo ich 2016 mehr über bewusstseinsgesteuerte Therapeutika erfahren kann.
Lass uns einen Blick darauf werfen.
Seit dem Jahrhundert.
Die Behandlungsstrategie bleibt also suboptimal.
Wir gehen zum Arzt, wenn wir uns krank fühlen, und der Arzt diagnostiziert die Krankheit und verschreibt je nach Körpergewicht ein paar Pillen.
Dies ist eine sehr schlechte Therapie, da die Diagnose immer zu spät kommt.
Wir waren bereits krank und die Dosiergenauigkeit auf der Grundlage des Körpergewichts ist unser Ziel.
Aus diesem Grund arbeiten wir auch an der Behandlungsstrategie der Zukunft, nämlich dem menschlichen Design von Zellen, menschlichen Zellen, die wir so konstruieren, dass sie das Krankheitssignal im peripheren Kreislauf präzise wahrnehmen.
Sie verarbeiten diese Informationen und produzieren, sezernieren und verteilen dann ein bestimmtes Medikament zur richtigen Zeit und in der richtigen Dosis.
Wir wollten das noch ein bisschen weiterentwickeln.
Wir wollten die Arzneimittelproduktion durch unseren Verstand kontrollieren.
Wenn der Körper also die Symptome spürt, wenn wir die Symptome spüren, denken wir einfach nach und verabreichen das Medikament dann zur richtigen Zeit und in der richtigen Dosis.
So lernen wir irgendwann, therapeutisch zu denken.
Eine Rolle des Geistes über die Materie zu spielen, ist ein sehr alter Traum der Menschheit, wie Yoda hier gezeigt hat, als er den X-Wing-Kämpfer von Luke Skywalker aus diesem Traum herausnimmt.
Egal, was wir mit unserem Gehirn machen, wir produzieren im Wesentlichen Elektrizität, die wir aufzeichnen, verarbeiten und mit der wir eine Lampe einschalten können, in einer Wissenschaft namens Operation, bei der die Wissenschaft das Verhalten menschlicher Zellen programmiert, indem sie Licht auf sie wirft.
Wir entwickeln ein solches optogenetisches Gerät mit Nahinfrarotlicht, das die Zellen beleuchtet und sie so programmiert, dass sie ein bestimmtes Medikament zur richtigen Zeit und zur richtigen Zeit produzieren.
Je länger wir diese Zellen beleuchten, desto mehr Medikamente produzieren sie, sodass wir endlich die Arzneimittelproduktion und letztendlich die sinkenden Werte im Kreislauf einstellen können.
Wir könnten auch einfach das Licht ausschalten.
Und so geht die Arzneimittelproduktion wieder zurück.
Und durch das Zusammenspiel von Licht ein- und Ausschalten des Lichts können wir die Arzneimittelproduktion ausschalten oder einschalten.
Wir können die Produktion nicht nur präzise dosieren, sondern uns auch an die Dynamik der Krankheit anpassen.
Wie verbinden wir das mit der Genexpression zur Gedankenkontrolle?
Wir haben den Probanden mit einem Headset ausgestattet und so die Gehirnaktivitäten aufgezeichnet und dann „Follow Gram“ gesagt, mit dem wir programmieren.
Also lasse ich dich gehen und dir das ansehen.
Sie beschweren sich immer noch über die Kontrolle und Sie schreien immer noch Leute wie mich in The Daily an, weil sie Menschen über etwas aufklären, was wir in der Wissenschaft jeden Tag tun, was wir jeden Tag in der Hochfrequenztechnologie tun.
Und ich werde jetzt noch eine Sache tun.
Wer ist Ihre Defense Threat Reduction Agency?
Wow.
Sieht aus, als wäre das keine seriöse Organisation.
Überhaupt nicht.
Lassen Sie mich Ihnen eine weitere sehr seriöse Organisation zeigen.
Und das ist wieder die Gefahr, wenn man weiterhin Menschen anlügt, weil man das Gefühl hat, dass es sein Recht ist, das zu tun.
Oder glaub mir, ich kann dich hören.
Ich verstehe es.
Du hattest deine kleine Viehherde, egal wie du sie hast, du hast sie immer noch.
Du brauchst dir keine Sorgen zu machen.
Es gibt nicht viele Leute hier auf meinem Kanal und wird es auch nicht geben, weil sie all ihre Freunde verlieren werden.
Die Marine ist bestrebt, einem größeren Teil der US-Flotte virtuelle Schulungen anzubieten.
Forschungsinteressen Eng verknüpft mit der Mikroelektronik.
Pentagon wurde geschlossen Technology Gap Get Air Right, um auf dem Schlachtfeld zu gewinnen, huh und Turkeys How the Sun Tests Robots Drones Swarm für digitales Truppenkonzept.
Und Nordkorea sagt, sein zweiter Versuch, einen Spionagesatelliten zu starten, sei gescheitert.
Lassen Sie Soldaten nicht von Maschinen fernhalten.
Kombiniere sie.
U.S.
Die Armee bittet die Industrie um Beiträge zur Materialliste für künstliche Intelligenz, wie der Kreislauf der Autonomie bewältigt werden kann.
Der Hype ist in Shut Up.
Wir tun, was wir tun.
Das Pentagon richtet die Task Force Lima ein, um generative KI-Themen wie Cyber und den Schutz kritischer Infrastrukturen im Zeitalter der Quantencomputer zu untersuchen.
Ups, dafür Politik in Ohio.
Scrollen Sie für Sie zurück nach oben.
Okay, Ihr Militär, wie Sie es 1995 kannten, ist übrigens seit 2012 weg und wurde 2017 eingeführt.
Nun, glauben Sie, dass die Eltern und Kinder in diesem Land in der Lage sein möchten, in einem normalen Gespräch miteinander zu kommunizieren, ohne sich darüber zu streiten, ob elektronische Kriegsführung nur auf Panzer und Flugzeuge abzielt oder nicht, darüber, ob es überhaupt eine gibt oder nicht?
Sind nicht involviert.
Schau dir das Bild an.
Lass mich dir hier ein größeres Bild machen.
Okay.
Siehst du, der kleine Kerl hat eine kleine Blase über seinem Kopf und die Drohnen, die ein Signal herunterscheinen, um zu sehen, dass jeder einzelne Soldat eine Blase auf seinem Kopf hat und die Drohnen ein Signal herunterscheinen.
Also den Leuten nur Panzer und Flugzeuge zu erzählen und ihnen dann von elektronischer Kriegsführung zu erzählen, ich habe keine Ahnung, wovon Sie sprechen.
Ich verstehe nicht.
Warum sprichst du das an?
Das ist dämlich.
Das haben wir nicht.
Und selbst wenn wir es tun würden, verwenden wir es nicht bei Menschen.
Das alles dient dazu, das zivile Zielprogramm zu isolieren.
Und das weiß ich auch zu schätzen.
Das tue ich.
Weil die Leute gerne so tun, als ob wir nur die Bösewichte kriegen und nur die Bösewichte ins Visier nehmen.
Ich denke, du musst damit aufhören.
Und ich denke, man muss die Leute ausbilden.
Und ich erzähle dir das alles seit anderthalb Jahren.
Du hast nicht das Recht, Leute einfach nach Belieben stumm zu schalten.
Und genau das werden sie tun.
Dieses System wurde gebaut, um zu töten.
Es wurde nicht gebaut, um irgendjemanden außer ihnen durch ihre Genetik zu schützen.
Das ist eine Biofrequenzwaffe.
Das ist es, was es tut.
Zusammenfassend lässt sich sagen, dass Sie bei dieser ganzen Ausbildung die Blutbahnen der Menschen intern in Echtzeit beobachten, genau wie Sie alles andere mit Nanoavionik und Elektrozeutika beobachten.
Unsere Lieben können nicht 5 Minuten still sitzen, wenn wir sagen: Hey, da ist ein Körperteil daran beteiligt.
Und das liegt immer noch an dir.
Sie benötigen Ihre Fähigkeit, sich in die Venen und Arterien von Menschen einzuloggen und ihre DNA neu zu ordnen, was meiner Meinung nach Ende des 19.
Jahrhunderts wirklich zu gedeihen begann.
Als du die Radiofrequenz abgeschafft hast, hast du alles verschwinden lassen.
Niemand weiß, dass wir vor langer Zeit WLAN hatten.
Warum sollten sie?
Und dann hast du dich versteckt.
Duh.
Versteckt.
Du hast all deine Arbeiten im Body Area-Netzwerk versteckt, weshalb wir heute hier gelandet sind und alle denken, es ist alles Science-Fiction.
Es ist nicht möglich zu glauben, dass sie einen Ausweg haben.
Tun sie nicht.
Und um alles noch schlimmer zu machen.
Du hast 2012 iPads an kleine Nerds verteilt, Willy Nilly.
Sie haben sich nicht die Mühe gemacht, jemandem etwas von dem zu erzählen, was Sie getan haben, und sind geradeaus marschiert, um ihnen eine drahtlose Gesundheitsversorgung zu bieten und ihnen die Fähigkeit zu nehmen, ihre eigene Haut zu fühlen, während Sie ihnen gleichzeitig gesagt haben, dass es Dämonen und Hexerei sind.
Wirf Zaubersprüche auf dich mit Geomantie und Zauberwirker und mach dich bereit für die Aliens.
Weil es nie jemanden gab, der uns den Zugang zu unserer eigenen elektrischen Anatomie und der Fähigkeit, unsere eigene Haut zu fühlen, zurückgeben würde, was beweisen würde, dass es sich nur um menschliche Kommunikation handelt, die reichlich vorhanden ist.
Ja.
Den Sixth Sense komplett wegzunehmen und ihn mithilfe künstlicher Intelligenz vollständig zu verwurzeln.
Du bist dir nicht sicher?
Hier, lass mich dir helfen.
Gehen Sie einfach direkt auf die Seite für Sie.
Ja, genau das haben wir vor.
Du hast fünf Sinne.
Die sechs Sinne.
Eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf.
Der Rest ist da.
Es heißt synthetische Telepathie.
Du wirst nie gefragt, wo Telepathie war.
Ihr sechster Sinn wird also auch zu Hadoop, Soup, Hive und Spark.
Weil Ihre Neuronen in Echtzeit mit diesen Nanokonstellationen kommunizieren, nicht mit anderen Menschen.
Oh nein.
Jep.
Und dann schauen sie es sich an und übertragen es mit Unternehmen.
Dies ist ein Unternehmen mit Produkten, wie Sie sehen können.
Wenn wir den Leuten also nicht sagen, was wir tun, wenn wir jeden Tag zur Arbeit gehen, haben wir am Ende Dinge wie das, womit ich später zurückkomme.
Wie man vor vier Jahren einen Menschen bei einem Tattoo fernsteuert.
DARPAs Terahertz zeigt Ihnen alles über den Terahertz-Raum und alles.
Und unsere Art, wie Gedankenlesetechnologie Ihr Gehirn erobert.
Vor drei Jahren nahmen unsere Lego-Biologiesteine, die wir zur Proteinkodierung verwenden, ein Transkriptom und spielten mit Menschen und rasen dann mit diesen Legosteinen ihren Körper hinunter.
Regenerative Medizin war Dr.
Michael Levin, in dem wir noch einmal durchgehen werden, wie wir vorgehen und die Drehpunkte und Mechanismen der Evolution verändern, um mehr genetischen Raum zu schaffen, in dem der Homöostase-Kreislauf geschlossen ist.
Das Gehirn passt Verhaltensprogramme dynamisch an unterschiedliche Körperarchitekturen an.
Und willkommen in der regenerativen Medizin.
Transkriptionsraum.
Das ist richtig.
Morphischer genetischer Raum.
Mit dem Automaten.
Das ist richtig.
Wo Alan Turing und Mr.
von Neumann wollte schon immer die Möglichkeit haben, sich in den Körper von Menschen einzuloggen und eine genetische Veränderung vorzunehmen, um sie drahtlos zu verändern.
Und niemand wird jemals wieder krank sein.
Sie werden unsterblich sein.
Mm hmm.
Molekül oder, Sie wissen schon, Zellgewebe, Organismus, Population, Gemeinschaft, Ökosystem und Biosphäre.
Sprengsätze.
Mm hmm.
Und dann die Kugelmathematik, die mit dem Smith Wheel verwendet wird, und alle möglichen lustigen Dinge, soweit wir Beamforming verwenden, um mit Ihrem toroidalen Feld auf jeder beliebigen Ebene zu spielen.
Und dann ändern wir das einfach hin und her, denn denken Sie daran, Sie glauben nicht, dass Sie drahtlos sind, und selbst wenn, sind Sie sicherlich mit nichts verbunden.
Wo sind die Neuronen, mit denen sie sprechen?
Neue Materialien für neuromorphe Systeme und Geräte, Anwendungsprogrammierung, Schnittstelle und Hyperwachstumstransferprotokoll gemustert.
Und was machen wir?
Wir betreiben Physik und Computer sowie elektrische digitale Datenverarbeitung mit fortschrittlicher Signalverarbeitung am Backend des Cisco-Flugzeugs.
Wir haben ein softwaredefiniertes Netzwerk, das all diese dynamischen Kanäle in und aus Ihrem Gewebe portiert, weil Sie ein Knoten im Netzwerk-Hypergraph sind, der für räumliche Spektren während der Merkmalsextraktion und Hyperspektralbilder eingebettet ist.
Und diese Hyperbilder sind Ihr Gehirn und Ihr Gewebe, die chemisches und energetisches Wissen zwischen molekularen Systemen übertragen.
Erinnern Sie sich vom Nano bis hin zu den Makroprotein-Interaktionsnetzwerken an all die Verbindungsvorhersagen mit Hypergraphen, die hin und her gehen, zu den künstlichen neuronalen Netzwerken in der Atmosphäre um Ihren Kopf herum.
Das wird weitergehen und die ganze Mathematik für sie wieder zusammenfügen.
Dann die Biophotonik-Anwendungen, wie wir diese Photonen wellenleiten, von denen er gerade gesprochen hat, mit dem Ein- und Ausschalten des Lichts in Ihrem Inneren in Echtzeit.
Ja.
Und das tun sie für Jobs.
Absolut.
Biolaser.
Sie sind sehr klein.
Sie befinden sich im Inneren mit der optischen Pinzette, wie optische Blattpinzetten zur optischen Manipulation von mikroskopischen Partikeln und lebenden Zellen.
Optische Pinzette mit optischem Strahl.
Mm hmm.
Sicherlich wissen sie nicht, was sie tun.
Auch hier waren wir mit all dem einfach so weit fortgeschritten.
Ich weiß wirklich nicht, wie irgendjemand in der Lage sein wird, seine eigenen Kinder zu retten, denn wenn du mit diesem Zeug nicht einverstanden bist, wirst du auf die eine oder andere Weise eingesperrt werden.
Und Tiefkühltruhe, nicht wahr?
Sie werden niemandem erlauben, sich außerhalb des Bereichs ihrer Tastensteuerung zu befinden.
Hier sind wir.
Wir haben also flüssige Neuronen in unserem neuromorphen Computing.
Du solltest wahrscheinlich umziehen, weißt du, einfach besuchen.
Diejenigen, die da drin sind, haben bereits eingebettete Chipsätze in ihrer linken Hemisphäre.
Es ist für sie einfacher, die neuromorphen und ionentrischen resistiven Speichergeräte und ihre Anwendung für neuromorphe Computer zu verwenden und mit ihnen zu arbeiten.
Wir haben auch einen widerstandsfähigen Speicher für ionische Flüssigkeiten und einen weichen und flexiblen Kern.
Also ionischer flüssigkeitsresitiver Speicher für elektronische Synapsen.
Künstliche Synapsen ermöglichen neuromorphes Rechnen vom Bauplan bis zur Realität.
Schematische Darstellung.
Okay.
Jüngste Fortschritte bei künstlichen synaptischen Geräten.
Da haben wir's.
Okay.
Also zeig zwei Leute und sag ihnen, dass sie ein Star Seed, ein Supersoldat, ein Alien sind.
Du könntest ihnen sagen, was du willst.
Die Holographie wird sich einloggen und ihren Blutkreislauf außer Kraft setzen.
Und jetzt haben Sie ihnen Graphen injiziert, was das noch schneller machen wird, denn genau dafür wurde Graphen für neuromorphe Chipsätze mit Terahertz-Low Power untersucht.
Und das alles brauchten wir für das Folgende.
Äh, hm.
Ja.
Tun sie nicht.
Sie haben keine Ahnung, was vor sich geht.
Nein, nein, tun sie nicht.
Tun sie nicht.
Sie wissen nichts.
Sie befinden sich immer in einer solchen Sackgasse, um dein Leben zu retten.
Sie haben keine Ahnung, wie Ihr Körper funktioniert.
Nein.
Und das tun nur diese seltsamen alten New-Age-Leute.
Und sie sind nicht komisch.
Sie sind so weise.
Sie wissen, wie man ihre Venen und Arterien entfernt und trotzdem herumläuft.
Ist das nicht etwas?
Ja.
Mhm.
Biologische Maschinen, DNA, Steganographie.
Alle wissen, dass wir Ihre DNA nicht durchforsten und Dinge darin verstecken, Daten daraus entnehmen und DNA-Sequenzen kontrollieren, mit wem Sie sprechen und mit wem nicht.
Oh nein, diese Fähigkeit haben wir nicht.
Oh nein, nein, keine Ahnung, wovon du sprichst.
Keine Ahnung.
So wie wir nicht wissen, dass der Körper elektrisch ist.
Ja, es ist alles nur falsch.
Falsch, falsch.
Weil du nicht fragst oder nicht das richtige Wort benutzt.
Probieren Sie Bioelektrik und fortgeschrittene Signaltechnik, Gewebetechnik, Biomedizintechnik und Gentechnologie aus.
Du wirst den ganzen Tag hier sein.
Regenerative Medizin enthüllt den genetischen Morpho-Code.
Wenn Sie unseren Kindern also sagen, dass Sie anfangen und einfach hier sitzen und mit der Luft kommunizieren müssen, ist das perfekt, denn darauf lernen die künstlichen neuronalen Netzwerke für Berührung, Hören, Sehen, Riechen und Schmecken.
Deine Telepathie ist synthetische Telepathie und dein Einfühlungsvermögen wird außer Kraft gesetzt, weil sie wollen, dass du sensibel auf Maschinen reagierst und Schmerzen hast, wenn du auf andere physische Menschen triffst.
Einiges davon wurde bereits getan, und dann wird Ihre Fähigkeit, mental zu verarbeiten, damit verbunden sein, dass Funken durchbrennen und der gesamte Hive-Datenbankzugriff erfolgt.
Die haben auch Namen.
Wie Sie sehen können, ist dies 2015, 17, 18, 19, 20, 21, 22.
Für mich sieht es so aus, als wären sie zur Arbeit gegangen.
Für mich sieht es so aus, als ob es ihnen gut geht.
Und für mich sieht es so aus, als ob das 2020 heißt.
Ich glaube, das COVID wurde hier 2019 eingesetzt.
Für mich sieht es also so aus, als hätten sie Sie über das belogen, was sie wirklich getan haben, was ein cyberphysisches Rückgrat für Ihre Ingenieure für Ihre neue Medizin und Biologie ist.
Je früher Sie also intellektuell mit Menschen kommunizieren können, desto besser.
Und deshalb habe ich Vorladungen ausgeworfen, weil hier wirklich das Problem liegt.
Wenn ich diese Vermutungen anstelle und Sie jemanden haben, der Sie ansieht, ein Gesicht macht und sagt: Nun, ich bin ein Arzt für, Sie wissen schon, wählen Sie es aus oder ich bin ein Experte dafür, Sie wissen schon, es auszuwählen, und dann lügen sie Sie an.
Das ist alles, was sie tun müssen, denn du wirst ihnen glauben und keiner deiner Freunde glaubt dir.
Und Konflikte sind zum Kotzen.
Also sitzt du einfach da und das ist es, was ihnen noch einmal erlaubt hat.
Ich glaube das seit 2019.
Ja.
Und was ich Ihnen sage, ist, dass das cyberphysische Rückgrat, das sie dafür brauchten, für diese Dinge auch hier, und es gibt eine Menge von ihnen, die besser funktionieren, sie hatten sie 2017 und ignorieren die DNA-Steganographie, die seit den fünfziger Jahren gelebt wird.
Kannst du mir erklären, wie das geholfen hat?
Weil ich dir sagen werde, dass es nicht so war.
Und jetzt werde ich einfach scrollen, weil ich möchte, dass Sie sehen, welche Arbeit dieser besondere Herr geleistet hat und wie viele Videos er über Optogenetik aufnehmen konnte.
Das Global Governance Forum befasst sich mit den Schwerpunkten Optogenetik zur Verbesserung der Gehirnfunktion, Neurotechnologien und aktuelle Entwicklungen.
Harvard Medical School, Optogenetik, die den Weg zur kausalen Neurowissenschaft ebnet.
Dieser ist wirklich interessant, sagte Optogenetik.
Und Optogenetik ist dieser Fall Western Reserve University, das Allen Institute zur Manipulation von Neuronen mit Licht Optogenetik entwickelt schmerzähnliches Verhalten bei Mäusen, Bioethik, Hacking, die Verbesserung der Gehirnneuronen mit nichtinvasiver Gehirnstimulation.
Optogenetik der Universität von Alabama 2017 Reverse Engineering the Brain National Human Genome Research Entschlüsselung von Epigenom-Karten des Gehirns mit hellen Signalen, die das Gehirn auskleiden.
Boston Children's Hospital Magnetic Control of Cellular Signaling 2011 Die weichen elektronischen und mikrofluidischen Systeme der Northwestern University für den menschlichen Körper, digitale Zwillinge, DNA-Speicher und mehr mit dem Auge Tripolis USA Präsident Thomas Coughlin im Jahr 2020 Mobile come 2015 menschliche Sensorik mit sichtbarem Licht Kommunikation 2015.
Das ist der einzig gute Herr, den ich gerade lerne, weil er riesig ist.
15.
August 2023.
Ihr Auge Tripolis 4 bis 6 G Woo i Tripolis.
MVS Diejenigen, die wir gerade bei tragbaren Sensoren und Sensornetzwerken für Präzisionsmedizin und KI Tripolis waren.
MVS Medizin und Biologika.
Wir veranstalten ein Symposium zu Precision Medicine, und Sie werden gleich hier sehen, dass es Ihr EEG und die Übersetzung mit künstlichen neuronalen Netzwerken hat.
Und ich schätze, die Flüssigkeit wird dort für sichtbares Licht sein.
Kommunikation mit der Telekommunikation, eine globale und Einführung in die Kommunikation mit sichtbarem Licht Luciferase.
Velshi Neue Lasertechnologie kann wie nie zuvor in unseren Körper hineinschauen.
Dann sechs g Radio-Terahertz-Sensorik.
Nun, das ist ziemlich cool, es sind weniger als 5 Minuten, I Tripolis Webinar on 64 A Hyperconnected Future 2021 Terahertz-Spektrum kommt in 60 Optical Communications und das ist erst vor zwei Tagen.
Mit anderen Worten, für diejenigen unter Ihnen da draußen, die nicht glauben, dass Sie dieses Zeug finden und darüber herausfinden können, empfehle ich diesen Typen auch.
Es ist wirklich interessant, ihm zuzuhören und er ist sehr genau.
Was ich den Leuten sage, ist, wenn sie dich anschreien, du gehst zu Command and Control und sagst: Wie viel davon ist digital?
Steht da elektronische Kriegsführung?
Das tut es sicher.
Was heißt das?
Heißt das unbemannt?
Das tut es sicher.
Diese werden Buttons genannt.
Es sind schnelle Klicks.
Was machen sie hier oben, wenn sie so unbekannt sind?
Weil sie bekannt sind.
Das sind Jobs.
Auf welchen Körperteil zielt die Drohne ab?
Mit welchem Körperteil interagieren diese künstlichen Intelligenzsysteme?
Nutzer aktivieren, versenden?
Ja, weil sie es ändern.
Sie haben das Signal in dir übertragen.
Ich kann Ihnen nicht sagen, auf wie viele Arten ich nicht zustimme.
Es spielt keine Rolle.
Sie haben es schon seit den fünfziger Jahren gemacht und sie werden es nicht zurückgeben und sie werden es nicht ausschalten.
Sie werden Menschen mit Hybriden erschrecken und ihre Luftkissenfahrzeuge fliegen lassen.
Und wir müssen es als freilaufende Menschen auf die andere Seite schaffen, die sich nicht hingezogen fühlen wollen, die keine cyberphysischen Parteien sein wollen.
Falscher Klick.
Schau, wie schwierig es ist, das alles zu erklären, und dann schreien mich alle an.
Du machst es nicht schnell genug.
Ich weiß nicht, wie das irgendjemand schnell genug machen kann.
Das tue ich wirklich nicht.
Es gibt so viele Materialien, auf die man immer wieder zurückgreifen kann.
Mit anderen Worten, dies geschah 2017, genau im Einklang mit der Pentagon-Richtlinie D.O.D.
3.000,09.
Solange du dich damit nicht auseinandersetzt, bist du tot, weil du dafür keine Triage hast.
Du verstehst nicht.
Glaubst du, es ist Bewusstsein?
Nee.
Es ist dein bioelektrisches Körperteil.
Es wäre an den Leuten gelegen, dir zu sagen, dass sie es nicht getan haben.
Nun, ich habe es getan und andere versuchen es.
Also gib ihnen bitte deine Zeit und Aufmerksamkeit, wenn du kannst.
Mark 536 Lebe den Tag sogar.